mon
bonjour françoise bonjour corinne il a
bien avancé le chantier quand même oui
oui il a bien avancé et effectivement on
a des doutes depuis un an
qu'est ce qui vous a donné l'envi au
départ avec votre mari de construire une
maison en paille
nous avons découvert les maisons en
paille sur internet et c'est vrai que
rapidement on a eu envie de se lancer
aussi voit la paille finalement pourquoi
la paille parce que c'est un très bon
isolant et puis c'est des constructions
qui sont qui permettent de de faire une
maison à un prix très très raisonnable
l'aventuré a commencé en 2011 pour cette
famille installée dans la drôme et qui
souhaitait revenir en val de loire
la terre a été récupéré sur place et les
ballots de paille crouler dans une
ossature bois de 50 cm de large
oh
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer françois ce convoi de ce mur
pour l'instant à semur en fait
et bien c'est l'argile du terrain quand
on a fait des quais celle vieira ou le
tout à fait quand on a fait des cas
c'est le terrain et qu'on a fait creuser
les fondations on a demandé aux
terrassiers de nous mettre de côté toute
la terre argileuse et donc à cette terre
on l'a où on l'a récupéré on la tribune
enlever toutes les pierres c'est un
travail herculéen travail complètement
fou on l'a mélangé avec du sable de la
chaux de la sueur pour armer le mélange
et de l'eau tous à la bétonnière avec
les sauts avec les brouettes
alors ça vient par dessus la paille
voilà c'est ça ya environ 4 cm
d'épaisseur entre la paille est ce qu'on
voit et ça protège la paille de
l'humidité etc du cheveu parce que s'il
y avait un incendie ça cuir et la terre
ça ne brûlerait pas
où
ici c'est le côté nord dont petite
petite fenêtre ça il ya trois petits
fenestron seulement le côté nord pour
éviter de faire rentrer froid avec des
grandes villes important dans
l'orientation dans toutes les
constructions trois ans de travaux et
pendant ce temps les guillerme et leurs
deux enfants ont vécu dans une drôle de
cabane au fond du jardin
donc ça c'était votre première maison
c'était ma première maison déjà en
paille c'est ça c'était le sait le
modèle réduit quoi c'est le modèle
réduit mais pas du tout avec la même
technique donc là il n'y a pas de
ceinture bois c'est des bottes de paille
posés comme des parpaings et qu'on a
qu'on à brochets avec des morceaux de
bois qu'on avait taillé et donc bah on a
été très bien dans cette cabane on
s'était fait une mezzanine on dormait à
l'étagé notre fils dormait en bas on
avait notre petit coin cuisine c'était
parfait
et les fondations été faite d'une façon
particulière alors les fondations c'est
des fondations cyclopéenne fait avec du
béton romain c'est à dire que dans le
fond des fondations on a mis des grosses
pierres qu'on a baigné dans du béton de
chaux et plus on est monté plus on a mis
des pierres de plus en plus petit pour
arriver jusqu'à un peu plus bas que ce
qu'on voit et après on a mis deux
auteurs de briques de soubassement sur
deux rangées et c'est là-dessus après
qu'on a posé la paille en fait d'accord
je vous fais court parce qu'il ya toute
une ossature bois en pleine réflexion et
plein de techniques qui sont alternatif
finalement c'est ça
à l'origine du projet dominique le mari
de françoise s'est fait la main sur
plusieurs chantiers participatifs
car il n'y a pas de norme constructif
pour les maisons en paille
aujourd'hui cette maison suscite
l'intérêt de nombreux visiteurs
ce sont des curieux y les gens viennent
s'arrête devant chez nous regardent pose
des questions ouais ça intéresse
beaucoup et il passe à l'acte ou pas en
général ça dépend si ce sont des jeunes
personnes ils peuvent passer à l'acte
alors tous les deux vous avez choisi de
faire par vous-même c'était pour des
raisons économiques ou écologiques
moi je dirais les deux on avait envie de
montrer aussi qu'on peut construire une
grande maison parce qu'on a quand même
140 mètres carrés habitables tout en
dépensant quand même très peu d'argent
je dirais qu'on devrait finir le
chantier entre 50 et 60 mille euros pour
la maison et puis utiliser la terre de
son terrain quoi de plus naturel
ça aussi c'est écologique puis c'est
sacrément économique économique encore
un petit poêle avec le tuyau à
l'extérieur pour la maison reste à faire
l'enduit qui lui donnera une apparence
presque normale
ç'a vraiment soudé la famille et puis
tout le monde est très très attaché à la
maison au lieu
c'est marrant je disais ce matin notre
fils et puis notre fille aînée pareil
nous dira non maison on ne l'est on ne
le vendra jamais où la garde c'est notre
maison c'est un sentiment d'appartenance
qui est encore plus grand quand on
achète quelque chose je pense l'avoir
vous ou à l avoir fait comme ça de ses
propres mains c'est même émouvant